hey welcome back to cmake
tutorial episode eight i think we're on
eight
today we're gonna talk about find
library
this is something i probably got the
most questions on just because it is
something that is all over the place i
haven't really explained it before
usually when i do external libraries i
just sub-module them and
but that's not what everybody does and
that's not really the standard that's
sort of uh
open source special case which i really
like but
find library i'm going to show you how
to get find library going
and talk about generally how it works
and the examples i'm going to use it for
are glue
glu and gl so basically
you're doing a project with that uses
glue and opengl
i'll talk about setup real quick we're
using the same project we've used in all
the previous ones
and just picking up where we left off
from episode seven
so if you haven't seen those and are
completely confused you might want to
start
somewhere at the beginning and i just
want to real quick
show that we have it installed i'm on a
linux environment
so on windows this might vary a little
the paths might be a little different so
first you need glue so you want to just
do like a
go to your terminal and do an app search
blue and you'll see live glue dev that's
the one you want for glue
so this is assuming that you have that
installed with sudo
apt-get install live
glue dev and yep i've got it
you could build glue or have glue
somewhere else and that's kind of the
point of find library
in case you have it somewhere else if
you don't have it and you try to link it
you're going to get an error length time
so if you don't have it
you can get an error before length time
with find library and that way you can
sort that out and maybe
find more info so this is probably going
to be a two-parter i'm going to explain
it
i guess it from the basics as much as
possible in this one on the next one i'm
going to talk about using
like the find modules a little bit
so i think it's necessary to split into
two parts because you can do it either
way and you see it done both ways
all right so in our project i have
opened the cmakelist.txt
now i am also using cmake 3.13.4
so if i do a cmake dash dash version
see i'm using 3.134 so i you got to be
careful to look at the documentation
for your version just fyi
there's a lot going on here so i'm just
going to take it off the screen so we
can look at one thing at a time
so find library you just type it like so
you can do it
kind of anywhere in here just you know
before you actually link basically
um which i do my linking way at the
bottom so i've got a lot of room to do
that
target link libraries so the first thing
here is a variable this is whatever you
want to name it you could literally just
like
you know smash your keyboard and that's
a valid name it's one of those type of
things
i just put my glue lib and then the
second thing
is the actual name of the live
and then afterwards you can put names
and you just have
optional names of what else it could
possibly be called
now of course this one when it searches
for this it assumes that it's looking
for a word with live in the front
and a dot a at the end for linux
so that's all assumed you don't have to
put that on there
and so in general really all you need is
that part right
there like i could get away with just
that we're calling we're calling the
the variable to tell whether it's found
or not
my glue lib and we're looking for glue
but if you want to have if you just want
to have it cover additional cases
that's when you put this name in here
and additional names and as you can see
i put a two at the end
i put just a capitalized version of it
in here not sure if that matters to be
honest but i thought i'd put it in here
anyway
just as an example and then you can
document with doc
and there's more stuff that i'm not
doing i'll just drag this over real
quick
make sure you're looking at the right
version when you look at this because
3.18
allows you to put things like required
in here
but 3.13 does not so require just
basically means it
it fails with a fatal error and tells
you hey you don't have this library
but when we go back to 3.13 there is no
required so
there is no option to auto fail if it
doesn't find it so i had to do it
slightly different because of that
so that's what this whole if else is
about if i could just
put required right here and have it
actually
function then it would be fine i could
just go like that
but since i'm using 3.13 that's just
what ships with this version of linux
then you have to do a if else case
basically
what happens here is if this is found
then this variable name just becomes the
path to that library
if it's not found it becomes
uh a dash not found it becomes this
variable right here
the name of it with the dash not found
well that evaluates to
false i think let me see here
yeah if nothing is found the result will
be var not found
the search will be attempted to find and
next time find libraries and vote on the
same library
but another thing about this found when
using an if statement so you can use a
string equal
to compare it to
not found you could say if my blue live
is equal to
that not found or you can just put it in
there as a macro to the variable because
cmake has a special canary
scenario evaluates to false
if it has a suffix not found on it
[Music]
so you can just put that in there i
don't know maybe
do they have that backwards though
because if this was false
then it would skip over it and if it was
true so you would think that there would
be a knot in front of here but when i
put not
in front of this then it messes up and
does the wrong thing
so i'm not sure on that documentation
so when i hit um run cmake on this
it basically says blue found
as my glue live not found so it's not
finding it right
so i guess i do have to have the knot
here
and there we go now it works so why
isn't it finding this
i'm actually confused because it was
just a bit ago
so i got something named wrong i guess i
need to delete my cmake cache or
something
this is not failing i'm really confused
about why this is not failing
oh it's because it's in build not
out.build i think i changed that at some
point
now let's watch it fail yeah okay there
we go
my glue live is not found
see uh yeah this is where it says has
not found that's kind of buggy
so i guess we do need this knot in front
of it
okay now it properly says okay so yeah
if this has a not found on it evaluates
to false
and that way we need to flip it to true
so we get this fatal error and it goes
into this if step
statement so that's that's the point
there
so let's fix this
and build again do we need this knot
here or not
i'm i'm losing my mind with this crap
try it with the string equals okay so i
guess this is the more reliable
way to do it in my version is what this
string equals
otherwise it's pretty confusing with the
old not statement
cool and we got the messages here so
those messages come from that part right
there
so it does find all these so once again
let's just mess this up
and see what happens so let's mess up
glue
hit build again
it says it found it i guess it has it
cached i think it's just cache so we
have to delete this to mess it up
that's not normal usually if it found it
once you're good you shouldn't be
changing it right
so there we go says no clue sad day
now let's fix it so if it fails it
like i've read in the documentation room
again if it fails that's when it keeps
checking if it
if it finds it it doesn't keep checking
it just
it goes with it
all right so there we go we're good
there
that's going to be a pain to edit to
make that actually make sense
okay and then the only thing other thing
we do is we go down to target link
libraries
and we we're just going to add those on
as their variables so that way it
evaluates to
this whole thing right there
this tutorial broke me and now we would
have to actually
use these so if you're using glfw you do
have to use
include the glfw action afterwards
because glfw
also includes gl
okay so well that's basically how you
use the find library
let's quickly look at some of the other
options and i'll talk about putting in a
module in the next
one so the different options you have
here
instant paths are essentially the same
thing
and and what those are i already
explained what names are they're just
possible names for the library hints and
paths
are just other directories you want to
search and also there's path suffixes
which it checks with all the hints or
paths
in addition uh to those so just
slaps it on the end documentation it's
just some
some notes about what it is no default
path here if you turn this on it
basically
doesn't search uh all
your computer it only searches your
paths and hints
so this won't check uh it won't check
your environment
it won't check your current folder
basically unless you have it in these
hints and paths
so and it's kind of the same with these
no package group
no default path is both no package
root no c make path no and it's
basically note all of these i believe
or you can just specify hey don't search
these paths
and uh that's about it so let me know if
you guys have any questions hopefully i
can edit this to get
together in a way that made sense
because i i ran into a few hiccups as
you might have noticed
but let me know down below i'll try to
cover
everything in the next one when i talk
about putting these all in a module
like a find dot c make module because
that's what most people do because these
libraries often
they convolute up your root level cmake
can make it a little confusing so people
usually just put them in a subfolder
all right well happy coding and peace
out i'll see in the next one
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
you